can he not close his hand shaking his
boot there he's a little nervous this is
because he knows you have all the - yeah
he's got a bad Bluff hey everyone and
welcome back to potato mode where we
take the most beautiful games and turn
them into mush just absolute mush my
name is Joey and here with me today once
again is Rob Handler II hi it's great to
be back and as you can see we are going
to be plane Kingdom Come deliverance
yeah a game that you know it's pretty
recent and it looks pretty dang good it
does yeah I dig this game ID you know it
you know had to had its fair share of
bugs which I'm sure we'll see but I I do
love the immersiveness of this game and
how high you can jump on your horse
alright so what we're gonna do if you
haven't seen the show before we're gonna
showcase just kind of what the game
looks like on its highest settings and
we're gonna kind of gradually descend
into madness yeah by means of bringing
the graphics all the way down to their
lowest settings that the game will allow
us to and then we'll go even further by
doing a couple things that we probably
shouldn't do at home but we're gonna
show you that anyway and then kinda see
where that goes from there well let's
just let's get some nice scenic views
here yeah let's go into the menus real
quick and then go into settings
graphical settings and we can turn just
go straight down the line and go
everything to low right not too shabby
let's go on to the field see what it
looks like I think those flowers used to
sway in the wind and now nothing does
because I think that's what most of the
game is spinning its of resources on
mm-hmm just a lot of the lot of the
grass and trees and stuff but
pretty good surprisingly yeah yeah let's
see our horse and glorious 480p okay
there it is Oh oh yeah just like playing
uh Elder Scrolls - but you know what
it's still a - bad yeah do it there's
one thing this game is it has a very
good like base I think the structure is
really good like all the foliage
placement I think yeah let's park
ourselves in front of somebody okay and
a few things that we're gonna be doing -
the graphics oh boy okay so what's up
[Laughter]
okay so the two screens you're looking
at here are on the Left we have just the
Kingdom Come deliverance directory under
our steam app steamapps folder and on
the right side are a couple of text
documents that I have edited so that we
can kind of control what we want and
don't want from the graphics level of
detail distance ratio we have dynamic
lighting particles clouds motion blur
we're gonna drag it into here and then
we're gonna rename it user alright and
then we're going to the scenes from the
game once again Ivan let's remind people
to be very careful with trying these
settings at home because like I said
it's a very fragile game so what we're
gonna do is if you want to bring up the
console commands okay and then hit exe C
and then user and then hit enter this
looks okay just shabby actually what did
you do so this is a kind of like a
preset okay I found the to basically
kind of help with performance issues
let's try going to that town once again
I want to play hey me still so if you
look at yeah buildings like that you can
see it just looks like mud which I
assume is what they built it with it's
historically accurate right absolutely
let's go in here yeah there's a bar
right here oh this town really likes
hats just not when people are looking at
them so this is the one that I have
which is basically zero on everything
so let's park ourselves in front of a
person and then if you want to hit that
same
cup conflict man Exe see space user go
[Music]
[Laughter]
he looks like Kevin Bacon from Holloman
this is Holloman even put on a Henry
face right
it's like the sharpness of that ear
makes them look like an orc
what else has gone oh my god what else
is come on there's a what else is gone
bull like I mean I lock their insides
there's souls oh man well I should be
able to just walk I guess right have a
baby oh no it's just a table Skye is
damn good at squats look at but she was
even better at dice he's Holloman he's
Kevin Bacon
[Music]
I forgot there's something inside me
that makes me okay with the eyes as long
as the mouth still moves can he not
close his hand shaking his boot there
he's a little nervous this is because he
knows you have all the - yeah no he's
just more of like a germaphobe like he
doesn't want as fingers to touch this
disgusting cup that you were playing
with oh we should go into a forest if
you if you can make it out on it fear
alive
oh do that's such a good idea oh so
weird how everything like turns oh it's
like always facing you yeah it's like
old school well you know what that
reminds me of it's like like cruising
USA I don't know Oh
we'll walk through those it kind of
reminds me of those um those like
optical illusions where yeah they're
like they're sculptures but they're like
inverted so every time you move to the
left or right the face follows you right
they're here to welcome you yeah they're
here to welcome to come on in to our
lovely forest come on pebbles
I wonder cuz I have one more setting
available let's do it but that one is
the one that I don't know if it ever
works or is this one was all set to zero
this one right here is all set to
negative three let's put in there all
right that guy can execute user there's
a very good chance that this will crash
everything but I'm willing to take that
chance
for the sake of potato mode moving so
quickly Wow alright let's see if we can
actually
make it outside without the game
destroying itself definitely getting
some framerate checks here
it looks really dangerous look so
dangerous outside there's a lot of
lighting effects going on like this peak
or this Sun is now like just only a
couple miles from Earth we're trying to
be very apocalypse gnomes here we're
being very careful right now I don't
even go into walking mode the horror
game everything is just really really
bright glass yeah yeah you know what the
other thing too is if we get busted
I can't tell isn't so close yes that's
creepy though is like he could be
standing right there okay let's go
outside
[Laughter]
gentle I've ever seen anyone play again
oh I know right who would ever play a
video game like this like heaven emote
and yet you're still just kind of
shuffling have a half a step at a time
where's your horse Oh advice Bob my
horse that's what's gonna do it let's
try it it's so weird to think that like
someone could be standing like right in
front of you for the gist it's Rodriguez
solo he's right here huh I think it was
like this the square right here he still
looks okay oh that's what slow do not
gallop whatever you do oh my god you
know what's weird to think is like how
many people just walked by right now Oh
a lot I'm sure but like no one's saying
anything you know all right bet there's
someone sitting here just you if you
walk up to it and just punch
that's how they keep law and order in
this town that's invisible until they
see someone swing they walk up to him
[Music]
can we talk okay there's got to be
someone yeah I think this is the bar
this dude his hats back Fez hat we're
not wait this oh it's our guy his face
is back yeah I think doing negative 3 on
because I remember there was one setting
for facial animation
I guess zero means it's just completely
blank and and stiff but like if you go
into negatives like those starts going
the opposite direction
it's very strange like a lot of these
settings but as you can see it it does
change it into a potato I'm still really
disappointed we haven't found a potato
in any of these kitchens yeah yeah well
because there you go that is Kingdom
Come deliverance run on the potato
basically I kind of like how the punch
just comes straight out of your body
like yeah like see what your doom yeah
oh look at all these dialogue props
that's all these people anyway if you
guys have any suggestions for games that
you'd like to see run on the potato much
like we are seeing right now leave it in
the comments below and we might get to
it but for now thank you all for
watching this episode potato mode and
we'll see you next time
see you next time
what did I do
your resolution is way too low I'm sorry
boys finally must be at least 720p yeah
private area it's sleeping someone's
private bed oh hell yeah when you wake
up like I did all that just been a dream
sleep because you know that when we
break in someone's house as long as you
go to sleep
they won't notice you that has nothing
to do with the graphics that was
freaking weird